uh icons I'll give you an example so a
lot most of the times when I ask girls
how much they want a guy to make that
they would take seriously it it's
typically more than what they make well
I think I would prefer to date someone
that made at least what I make
preferably more but like I would
probably fit into that category but I
don't speak to me that way
yeah but the problem is like
um like what do you make over 75 000 yes
over a hundred not not anymore I had to
take a pay cut to come to the UK roughly
a hundred like maybe in the US I made
over a hundred and that was like six
months ago so 100 that's top ten percent
guy but that's what I'm making no and
that's and that's fine but men don't
care about your money so that it's like
nothing it's kind of like if a guy tells
us he has a shoe collection it's kind of
cool but we're not like attracted to it
we're like ass it's okay I mean I don't
know I mean I I understand your
perspective and I'm not saying that
you're wrong but like kind of going back
I'm sorry I don't remember your name but
Cairo Cairo what he was saying earlier
about this generation like we were being
cognizant of building generational
wealth like the conversations I'm having
with my friends like my peers my friends
who make over six figures like my male
and female friends like we are thinking
about like all the things that he talked
about that's the com those are types of
conversations we're having we're talking
about who we're what we're investing in
what stocks like that's like what's
happening within my Social Circle the
problem is women women talk about it but
like the data doesn't Stack Up women's
how much more you think a woman spends
in a lifetime than a man Even though
yeah I'm sure we'd like I'm not arguing
with like whether or not we spend like
that's not what I'm talking about but
what I am saying is that you said that
men don't care about what women how much
you make and I'm saying at least within
my Social Circles I haven't found that
to be the case because men that I have
communicated with men that I've chatted
to you guys have dated especially black
men like we want to build generational
wealth like we've seen we've experienced
what happens when that is not the
Forefront of the of like the
relationship so we talk about goals like
financial goals that we have like
together like I so I at least that's
what I've converted like when I have
this those types of Standards or wants I
should say that I would like for a guy
to make at least what I make
um so I'm I'm curious um the guys that
you're talking to are they your friends
yeah yeah and and you make a good amount
of money
they're probably trying to sleep with
you
they
yeah so I have a question okay
you you call them right now
I'm saying let's say I'm I'm in I'm in
I'm in one of you from New York right
from Virginia you said Virginia you're
from New York okay you're sorry I'm in
Virginia I'm horny can I come over yeah
wait wait wait all my platonic guy
friends in a relationship
I would never do such a thing
wait wait wait wait wait wait so what
why not if they'd say no because what if
I'm I'm not interested
wait you can you can tell them later
you can tell no you could tell him it
was a joke it was on the podcast it's
video evidence I don't I don't feel
comfortable with that dude
so so I don't even want to know the
answer to that question the point the
point the point I'm making though is
like okay if a guy is a CEO of a company
that's like sexy to women it's
attractive to see a guy in leadership I
mean I'll give you an example and this
isn't to be political but like
Melinda or Melania Melania and Donald
Trump like she's obviously better
looking than him why is she like
literally clearly why is she attracted
him he's the president that's an
argument
okay but you see what I'm saying
where your line of thought right but but
there's no men that are lined up to date
Oprah
Oprah no no even if she was single like
there's men Margot Robbie is married but
she's heavily desired like um Zendaya is
dating the Tom Holland dude but she
she's beautiful there's men that want to
date her yeah but it's nothing to do
with their money it's everything to do
with the way they look if she's if she's
hot and she has money they're like okay
cool but but it's not like they're
attracted to you for your money oh no
I'm not that wasn't what I was saying
either like I mean I'm obviously like
there's it's multi-dimensional like
there are a lot of things that go into
attraction like but again I'm used to
have this conversation of women to
expect or want men to make a certain
amount of money and then you set the
percentile of like what those earners
would be and I maintained what I said
earlier in that there is a specific
demographic of young professionals who
are taking what each their partner
brings the table into account outside of
sexual attraction so but the the issue
wait the issue is that when the the more
a woman makes and and I'm in this
category too like the more a woman makes
the more likely we are to be single no
and that's true like I'm not arguing
with that either I know this I know
that's like that's true like I I didn't
think about that like myself like uh how
far do I want to go in my career because
the further I go in my firm the least
the less yeah which is sad like I mean
that's like the less likely a man will
want to be with me yeah because like
because I like that just like I'm
literally like pricing myself out as I
continue to grow yeah because because
our our pool gets smaller and smaller
and those men I think about that yeah I
do those and those men want younger
hotter
yeah I mean it's it's true it's not fun
like I I I I wish like they cared but
they don't no yeah I mean that's just an
unfortunate scenario go ahead I'm sorry
some this isn't in my mind isn't
stacking up right you're having
conversations with uh your peers guys
friends all in the same sort of Social
Circle same Financial bracket yeah
um you guys are talking about how to
come together
um I'm I'm making an assumption
heterosexually yeah
um but at the same time in the very
beginning we said what would it take for
you to move in with a man and you and
you were pretty much like I'd rather run
away so on one hand you'd rather be over
here but on the other hand you're
talking in your Social Circles about how
to come together no that's not what I
said so when we talked about what what
are the two the two extreme options
would I rather move in would I be rather
be financially dependent on someone and
move in with the man or would I live
with the roommate and I chose living
with the roommate because I wouldn't
want that type of strain to be in my
relationship however I am a heterosexual
I want I might I want to get married I
want to have children like that doesn't
those two things would you depend on a
man like once you have kids 100 and I
hope he would depend and on me that's
what a marriage is you're depending on
each other I know I mean like
financially yeah okay so you'd be okay
with depending on a man after you're
married after he's my husband after he's
your husband and I would hope that he
would also depend like that's you depend
on each other I agree I agree yeah yeah
okay yeah that was clear thank you
um
yeah I don't think you guys answered um
the you ever dumped a girl because of
financial like just bad spending habits
um so I'm gonna say this in a Christian
perspective because I'm I was raised as
a Christian
so
um I never actually dated
uh
so as many of you know I was just banned
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible